la victoire de l'italien la finale de
l'euro de nos vins été célébrée dans
toute l'italie n'est pas ce sur toute la
planète dont la devise dur comme fer est
tout sauf l'angleterre sortie de vous
dont je parle les écossais et pour le
magazine the economist cette victoire
signifier quelque chose d'autre selon
eux le point le plus remarquable n'était
pas le jeu de l'italie mais le fait que
leur équipe n'ait aucun joueur de
couleur laissant de côté les trois
joueurs d'origine brésilienne
l'article évoqué également les
implications politiques de cette
victoire dans le contexte du bric site
mais détourner le sujet de ce qui est
important dans le talent et le football
pour faire de cette victoire une
question de couleur a suscité c'était à
prévoir
lire de la brigade anti wok sur twitter
beaucoup étaient perplexes quant à
l'importance donnée à la couleur de peau
de ses joueurs et d'autres ont souligné
que c'était peut-être le passé récent
mois impérialiste de l'italie qui
expliquer ce manque de diversité
d'autres accords ont rappelé que cet
article avait été rédigé alors que les
joueurs noirs de l'angleterre
subissez une avalanche d'insultés
racistes de la part de certains de leurs
propres supporters
une peinture murale représentant
l'attaquant anglais marcus trash ford
avait été vandalisé des supporters
anglais et italiens de couleur avait été
agressé par des hooligans raciste suite
à la défaite à wembley
verdict être les commentateurs anglais
devrait-il retirer la poutre de
l'oreille
avant d'insinuer que d'autres sont
coupables de racisme